okay so let's throw this Hakimi thing up
on
the screen and have a conversation about
this absolute weapon of a footballer
that's so golden so wife seeks half
Fortune discovers he owns nothing so
let's just read through this footballer
akimi's world was shocked a rock this is
his wife uh [__] this is his wife over
here she's cute uh filed for divorce and
demanded half his property several media
reports however in a surprising turn of
events the court informed her that her
millionaire husband legally owns nothing
as all of his assets are registered
under his mother's name Hakimi knows
that these hoes ain't loyal
no
akini the Moroccan International PSG
player received a staggering one million
dollars per month but 80 percent of this
amount is deposited to his mother
uh Miss Fatima's account the 24 year old
football star appears to have no
property houses jewelry or even close
registers I didn't even know that you
could register I thought that was weird
too uh the couple began dating in 2018
when Hakimi was only 19 and a book was
third hang on his wife is 31.
dude he was 19 and she was 31 when he
married her she has rest in [__] face
too holy smokes okay so that's
no wonder he I bet his mom had a
conversation with him was like you're
not marrying this chick unless you put
everything under my name I know what
she's all about 31 year old going for a
19 year old footballer World okay okay
uh as they head towards separation of
book now 36 anticipated receiving an
equal share of hakimi's 70 million
Fortune however documents reveal reveal
all of the assets our registered in his
mother's name leaving
a book with no legal claim
I can't believe he was 19 and she was
31. in an unusual Arrangement whenever
Hakimi needed something he requested it
from his mom who then purchased it for
him this Dynamic is allowed to avoid any
registration of Assets in his own name
the divorce proceeding came on the heels
of an investigation launched last month
in allegations the star Defender
molested a woman he had invited to his
matrimonial home while his wife and
family were in Dubai as the story
unfolds questions arise
about the motivation behind hakimi's
choice to keep all his assets under I
can tell you what the motivation is dude
it's very clear to me to protect his
assets
yeah now there is a problem with that
which they don't talk about in here and
this I don't know if this follows under
falls under Dubai law Moroccan law but
there's going to be some family like
this will fall under the jurisdiction of
some family law somewhere in the world
so here in Canada they've got this uh
notion of fraudulent conveyance right
and for those of you that don't know
what that means all that means is that
you can't go and and fraudulently uh
move assets around
um hide assets from like a bankruptcy
proceeding or to hide it from a
refinance from creditors
um you know from family law like you
can't just go and put all your assets in
your mom's name three months before you
go and file for divorce now if you did
it three years prior
or you did it before the wedding that's
probably a little more watertight right
but here here anyway it's about two
years so if you go and you know for
example move your uh move the title of
your home into your wife's name or your
kid's name or something like that and
you go and rack up a million dollars
with a credit card debt and you go file
for bankruptcies six months later the
um the courts will turn back the clock
on on the transfer of that asset and the
asset goes back into your name so the
creditors can liquidate it to pay off
the debts if it's very very close to the
date but I think in a situation like
this because he did it before he got
married and his mom told him to put
everything in her name before they got
married dude is probably pretty safe
it'll be interesting to see how this
unfolds this guy this guy is a g
right there although Devil's Advocate
what if it's something like he's a he's
a real mama's boy and he didn't even
know any better like he started making
all that money super young and she's
like hey I'll just take care of it and
you focus on Mom's a g then either way
somebody yeah somebody's getting pointed
somebody's getting credit somebody took
care of that issue somebody saw what's
coming
yeah
I actually wouldn't mind my mom managing
my finances she's done a good job with
hers just don't have to think about it
or anything happens to me anything crazy
down here I have it all going to my
sister because the problem with that
though is if you don't put all of your
assets into your mom's name for example
and she's elderly she could have health
issues you know she could be
hospitalized she could she get she could
get hit by a bus you got to have
mechanisms in place so that so that her
estate which is basically your estate
ends up sort of moving back into your
pocket through some tax-free mechanism
if you know what I'm saying
anyway it's something interesting that
article too and we see this a lot and I
think I think you kind of skirted over
it was um the the case what was it like
the the case was launched in response to
a woman claiming that she went she was
invited to his house and then he
molested her I always wonder like these
professional soccer stars who are these
girls that are and getting invited over
but don't want anything to move forward
and like oh he molested me because I I I
don't see that I don't hang out
necessarily famous people but I've
played Sports through college and I have
family members that have done really
well like all Allstate All-American type
stuff and they just have hordes of
[__] after them at all times the for
the little baseball team I played for
down here I had like groupies follow me
on the road so who are these girls that
are claiming molestation from a guy
who's making a million euro a month I'm
assuming he's pretty good that's a
decent Payday for him you've you've got
to be like you know when you get to a
certain level you've got to be careful
with women
um doesn't matter if you're an athlete
an influencer or an actor
um
I think uh Keanu Reeves there's a few
actors that are famous for this you know
whenever there's a you know they're
asked to pose in a photograph
they don't even touch the other person
they're just sort of like hovering like
the arms sort of hovering around them
sort of thing you know what I mean like
you got to be really careful I mean you
get DMS from girls that express interest
in you I wouldn't even get involved you
know you you know have your have your
inner circle that you trust like whether
it's your wife your girlfriend if you're
a guy that runs you know a little bit of
a hair and there's a couple of girls
that you trust women that have proven
themselves
they they get access to everybody else
you got to be careful with me you can't
follow fall for any of that [__]
what I used to balance in my old
balancing days like well what usually
happen is that the person I was
performing is that they get one of their
guys to come and just they put the cell
phone on the stage in front of the chick
and she just took the phone put it in
her number and then
um it wouldn't be tied back to the
actual performer to the guy that was
performing on stage
so interesting even back when um uh well
so obviously I'm from Canada but even
back when Prince Harry was in his chat
days you know in Calgary because um they
were actually doing training just
outside of Calgary and they would come
into Cowboys or whatever and then they
would have a bunch of people that would
come back to them to wherever they were
staying and then
they would take all their cell phones it
would make them sign some [__] and so
then like you know just nothing would
ever come out because there was no
evidence about anything coming out
um
turns out it looks like Hakimi lives in
Paris so that's probably where
um the jurisdiction will fall so I don't
know what French family law states but
um I guess we'll find out in the coming
uh months as that unravels I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out